[Risas]
[Música]
con lo que hemos vivido y sentido a lo
largo de la pandemia desde que recibimos
la noticia de la presencia del cob y 19
y del confinamiento hasta el día de hoy
que emociones han despertado esto en mí
seguramente incertidumbre incertidumbre
por ejemplo frente a la inestabilidad
laboral que vivimos pues hay muchas
personas que no cuentan con un trabajo
pero tienen deudas que pagar no son
obligadas cerrarnos en nuestras casas
pues ha sido la única manera de
mantenernos aparentemente a salvo pero y
qué tal qué pasa con esos hogares en los
que no existe una buena relación y donde
la convivencia se ha convertido en algo
muy difícil de llevar si a esto le
sumamos la preocupación por no contar
con los recursos económicos necesarios
para costear el tratamiento en caso de
contagiarnos la nueva realidad nos ha
obligado a enfrentarnos con un sinnúmero
de situaciones nuevas como
por ejemplo el teletrabajo que nos ha
permitido experimentar el estrés muy de
cerca puesto que combinar familia y
trabajo no ha sido fácil cuando nos
vemos en la necesidad de salir es
complicado y sentimos ansiedad pues
sabemos que el virus se puede encontrar
en cualquier lugar tratamos de mantener
el distanciamiento pero sabemos que esto
no en todos los lugares se respeta el
uso de la mascarilla es algo incómodo
que no nos permite respirar pero tenemos
que usarlo no nos queda otra salida
hoy por hoy sabemos que ya tendremos
acceso a la vacuna pero también sentimos
miedo por cómo puede reaccionar nuestro
cuerpo frente a ella extrañamos a
nuestros compañeros de clase extrañamos
a nuestros compañeros de trabajo
extrañamos poder salir a pasear viajar
visitar a nuestras familiares con
seguridad y todo el tiempo nos
preguntamos cuánto tiempo más va a durar
esta situación pensar en todo esto hace
que se aceleren los latidos de mi
corazón que no pueda respirar que me
duela la cabeza
siento muchas ideas que vienen y van
pero no las entiendo solo siento que un
malestar crece más y más ahora bien les
voy a pedir que ahí en el lugar donde
ustedes están cierren por un momento los
ojos vamos
hagámoslo cerremos por un momento
nuestros ojos y tratemos de silenciar
nuestros pensamientos
vamos a empezar a aspirar fuertemente
hasta contar 5
sostenemos del aire 123 y exhalamos por
la boca
una vez más tomamos aire
123 y exhalamos
vamos a intentar conectarnos con
nuestros sentidos
tratamos de percibir por ejemplo qué
ruidos se encuentran presentes en el
lugar donde estamos
tal vez escuchamos voces o pasos
aspiramos fuertemente y percibimos el
aroma del mismo lugar
tal vez huele a madera o alguna
fragancia
extiendo mis manos y trato de tocar
algún objeto puede ser una pulsera o
puede ser mi ropa que texturas puedo
sentir que costuras puedo sentir qué
formas puedo sentir
aspiro profundamente nuevo otra vez
y me doy cuenta que mis latidos
han regresado a su normalidad
que mi cabeza ya no me duele y que a
través de mis sentidos he podido
recobrar nuevamente la calma
aspiramos por última vez
sentimos la calma y cuando yo cuente 3
abrimos los ojos lentamente
volvemos al aquí y al ahora
muy bien
la pandemia los enfrentado a un
sinnúmero de situaciones momentos
agradables y otros devastadores pero sin
duda todos llenos de mucho aprendizaje
el confinamiento no es obligado a
cambiar drásticamente el ritmo de
nuestras vidas en muchos casos acelerado
tal vez por trabajo por hijos por
estudio pero con muy poco tiempo para
nosotros mismos y es aquí donde nos
hemos visto obligados a sacarnos de esas
máscaras de volver a lo que tenemos en
nuestro interior en muchos casos de este
reencuentro no ha sido positivo
ha despertado emociones difíciles de
entender y la necesidad de apoyarnos en
alguien más para poder aliviar este
malestar con el inicio de la pandemia y
el caos que se generó buscar apoyo era
realmente complicado para este momento
yo había considerado unirme a algún
grupo de apoyo y fue gracias a mi mejor
amiga que llegué al proyecto de sanando
mi ansiedad al inicio tuve muchas dudas
pues el miedo hace que busquemos excusas
para no arriesgarnos pero creo que la
vida nos presenta situaciones que nos
van formando para actuar en el momento
indicado
sanando mi ansiedad empezó como una
página de facebook que fue creada por
una persona que sufrió de ansiedad y que
vio la vida de su padre terminar a causa
de esta misma situación esta fue su
motivación y esto fue lo que a mí me
permitió identificarme con este proyecto
y decidí unirme
desde esta página empezamos a difundir
mensajes de motivación
empezamos a publicar vídeos con rutinas
de yoga y meditación para ayudar a las
personas a relajarse nuestro mensaje fue
bienvenido por muchas personas empezamos
a recibir reacciones positivas y esto
nos motivó a seguir adelante pues
nuestro objetivo de difundir un mensaje
que llegue a quienes lo necesitan se
estaba cumpliendo
pero los seres humanos somos sociables
por naturaleza y las personas empezaron
a demandar más interacción es entonces
que empezamos a desarrollar talleres
grupales virtuales y gratuitos en estos
talleres hablamos de temas como ansiedad
depresión
cada día se sumaban más personas a
nuestros talleres y esto nos llenaba de
mucha gratitud y satisfacción ahora bien
me gustaría preguntarles
si yo en este momento les pidiera que me
expliquen qué emociones son las que
ustedes han vivido durante este tiempo
creen que sería fácil si su respuesta es
no tranquilos esto es más común de lo
que nosotros imaginamos y nos permite
ver esas limitaciones que aún tenemos
como sociedad frente a temas de salud
emocional en muchos talleres pudimos
percibir el miedo en las personas al
momento de tener que expresar sus
emociones y eso nos hizo considerar el
hecho de poder ofrecer sesiones
individuales para que las personas
puedan sentirse más tranquilos y puedan
expresar lo que llevaban en su interior
la primera sesión de acompañamiento
emocional fue inolvidable pues a mí me
preocupaba mucho las limitaciones que
podríamos enfrentar al realizar una
sesión de este tipo por una videollamada
adaptabilidad es la manera en la que
surfeamos la hora del cambio
kelly slater
los seres humanos somos adaptables y la
nueva realidad nos obligó a hacerlo
mucho más en nuestras sesiones la
herramienta principal era el lenguaje
hablado pero había situaciones en las
que las personas no podían reconocer sus
emociones y peor aún expresarlas
es aquí donde me cuestioné si era
suficiente con una llamada para poder
ayudar y brindar el apoyo que estas
personas necesitaban realmente y la
respuesta fue no no era suficiente es
entonces donde empecé a buscar más
métodos y herramientas que me permitan
hacer más dinámicas estas sesiones
captar la atención de las personas y
lograr ese nivel de conciencia que nos
permita llegar a la raíz del problema y
poder darle una solución tal vez ustedes
han tenido un diario donde escribir los
sucesos más importantes de su día a día
quienes sí lo han tenido pues podrán
concordar conmigo que escribir nos da
esa sensación de liberarnos de aliviar
un poco las cargas es por eso que yo
motive constantemente a las personas a
que escriban logrando que un lápiz
y un papel se convierten en una
herramienta muy poderosa para poder
poner en orden todas esas ideas que nos
causan ansiedad o tal vez para escribir
una carta una carta de despedida una
carta de perdón o una carta de
arrepentimiento con el uso de la
tecnología del celular y de la
computadora hemos olvidado esa sensación
de poder plasmar nuestras emociones en
un papel utilizar nuestra imaginación y
trabajar con nuestro niño interior fue
algo muy importante es increíble ver
cómo a través de nuestras manos y a
través de los colores podemos expresar
tanto y darle forma a nuestro sentido
darle forma a nuestros sueños poder
representar nuestros miedos y darnos
cuenta que no son tan grandes como los
imaginamos contar nuestra historia a
través de dibujos las videollamadas se
han convertido en algo muy común y nos
permiten mantener el contacto con
nuestros familiares pero a la vez nos
permiten experimentar la impotencia de
ver el dolor tras una pantalla después
de un año me parece increíble cómo esta
situación me permitió
y entender que muchas veces las crisis
son situaciones que nos permiten
encontrar el potencial que llevamos
dentro a veces creemos que nuestro
propósito es tener una profesión pero yo
hoy creo que el verdadero propósito es
lo que podemos hacer con estos
conocimientos por ayudar a alguien más
sé que en este tiempo muchos han podido
lograr tener la conciencia de la
importancia de la salud emocional y les
pido que por favor levanten la mano
aquellas personas que han sentido
ansiedad o que conocen a alguien que
haya sufrido de ansiedad
somos muchos verdad
pues bien ahora ustedes se preguntarán y
qué hago si yo conozco a alguien como lo
ayudo o si soy yo qué hago pues bien
primero debemos tener mucha empatía
empatía para podernos poner en el lugar
de la otra persona y respetar su dolor
hace poco mientras revisaba mis redes
sociales vi una noticia que decía que en
el último tiempo el índice de
estudiantes con ansiedad y depresión
había aumentado
me llamó mucho la atención y quise
conocer cuáles eran las opiniones de las
demás personas frente a esta situación
fue lamentable encontrar comentarios
como eso les pasa por falta de oficio o
esto se resuelve con una correa
qué triste ver que no exista al respeto
por el sentir de las demás personas y no
señor no es por falta de oficio pero sí
por falta de empatía si nosotros
conocemos a alguien con ansiedad démosle
unos minutos para escuchar lo que nos
tiene que decir tratamos de cuidar
nuestras palabras para no herir para no
dañar todos tenemos cerca a alguien que
necesita de nuestra ayuda por favor
estemos atentos no nos desconectamos de
lo que es realmente importante
créanme que con pequeños acciones que
incorporemos a nuestra rutina diaria
estaremos contribuyendo enormemente a
nuestra salud emocional como por ejemplo
si podemos asignar 5 minutos al día
a la rutina de respiración que hicimos
al inicio van a ver como nuestros
niveles de ansiedad y de tensión van a
disminuir si tenemos muchos pensamientos
que están dando vueltas y vueltas por
nuestra cabeza y que nos quitan la
tranquilidad pues tomemos un estero y
una hoja y empezamos a escribir los
organicemos los en orden de importancia
y empecemos a resolverlos uno por uno
dibujemos o pintemos esto nos va a
ayudar a conectarnos con nuestras
emociones y nos va a permitir tener más
tranquilidad
en mente sana cuerpo sano asignemos unos
minutos para caminar o correr o tal vez
pongamos música en casa y bailemos esto
incluso puede convertirse en un buen
pretexto para compartir con nuestra
familia
y si al final nos damos cuenta que
estamos atravesando
una situación insostenible y que solos
no podemos
reconozcámoslo y busquemos ayuda
tal vez muchos hemos escuchado la frase
ir al psicólogo es para locos
pues no ir al psicólogo es para quienes
se preocupan por su bienestar emocional
reconocer que solos no podemos es más
valentía que debilidad
para finalizar quiero compartir con
ustedes una frase que fue mi inspiración
durante este camino y espero que también
pueda convertirse en la suya si logro
que una sola persona pueda tener
esperanza no habré vivido en vano martin
luther king gracias
[Aplausos]